I was believing in vitam is more
powerful yeah yo your real power when
you set up your environment correctly it
forces you it pushes you towards
discomfort towards the thing that is in
your best interest and prevents you from
acting against yourself who surround
yourself matters what content you
consume matters rise and shine it's an
spresso time what's up belief nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message set
wealth triggers over to you Dan lock so
you notice I have a lot of wealth
triggers in my office and so it's not
just decorative item everything means
something too right so I have like you
know the L okay death stocks that
represents personal branding yeah so I
don't think about that like leadership
energy or sure wisdom so everything is
dead in my office I wanted to I call
them wealth triggers yeah you should
this should create certain type of
feeling environment for me right I
always believe the environments more
powerful
yeah you're your real power right I
wanna stir so I have meetings here all
the time that's all sir
every week all those yeah yeah and then
have the Chinese kind of Friday there
yeah I'll see if I can translate that
basically means a kind of like the
autumn wall and battles one before is
ever fought right and and your decisions
affect
effect with the the outcome of the
battle even your like thousand miles
away right let's watch me oh that's cool
I like the katadyn yeah your motivation
sucks because your environment sucks
you're struggling day-to-day to stay
motivated to get on top to get fired up
for the day because everything in your
environment is centered around you
stayin exactly where you are instead of
pushing you towards discomfort and until
you fix that until you change your
environment until you're in an
environment that is inspiring and pushes
you forward you're never gonna get the
growth in one year from today if you do
not change your environment you will
stay in the exact same position with
zero momentum and zero growth when I was
18 years old I made one small change to
my environment that dramatically changed
the course of my life I had just come
back from Paris I had met a girl in
Paris that I wanted to ask out but I was
too chicken to do it and so I took a
picture as she was walking away from me
and I took that picture and I blew it up
and put it on my wall just like I have
these pictures on my wall at that time
it was a picture of this beautiful
French Riverside and that was a picture
for me that reminded me on a daily that
I did not want to live the rest of my
life in regret that was a change in my
environment that pushed me to discomfort
that the next time I had an opportunity
to do something but I was afraid to do
it
I would fast forward my life to age 90
and look back and say will I regret not
having taken action that visual that I
walked in and saw every single day was a
constant reminder for me and that's the
beauty of having an environment that's
designed for your success because it
only takes one day of taking action
these pictures all mean something to me
when I walk into this office it gets me
inspired it gets me feeling belief if
you walked into this office this may not
mean much to you but all of these people
means something to me I had to set that
up one time and now every time when I
walk into my office I get inspired and
so after a few months of having that
picture up on my wall when I was 18
years old I got an opportunity to go
join a new startup company and it was
the opportunity to either be with that
startup make $300 a month being owner in
the business or go get my dream job that
I thought I always wanted and because I
had that record on repeat because by
looking at that picture every single day
I
that record on repeat in my mind that I
do not want to live my life in regret I
do not want to regret the actions not
taken in my life that I had to examine
that decision should I join the startup
or should I go take my dream job dream
job and you know what I thought I could
always go and get another job like that
again it may not be the perfect job man
to be that same job but I can always get
a job like that again I don't know if
I'll ever get that opportunity to be an
entrepreneur again I don't know if this
kind of opportunity will ever show up
again and I would regret not taking
action on being an entrepreneur and so
because I had that picture in my
environment every single day looking at
that picture every single day having it
around me every single day it pushed me
towards discomfort it forced me to do
the thing that was actually in my best
interest even though my brain would have
acted against me would have told me to
go do the safe thing the smart thing the
thing that I thought I always wanted and
so when you set up your environment
correctly it forces you it pushes you
towards discomfort towards the thing
that is in your best interest and
prevents you from acting against
yourself okay so how do you do it how do
you set up an environment for success
I'm gonna give you three things to do
step number one is fix your walls your
desks and your screens think about
what's on your wall what is on your wall
where you spend most of your time
working this is what's on my wall you
can see it behind me these all mean
something deep and powerful to me design
your wall with intention second what's
on your desk so for me I've got a bunch
of things on my desk you can see my wife
my son my two books I've got other books
I've got things on the desk that again
inspire me what is the thing that
inspires you that reminds you of your
mission your one word the thing that you
don't want to regret the thing that's
gonna push you towards discomfort on
your desk as a constant visual reminder
and third there is the screens so what
is on your desktop background what is on
your phone background what are the
reminders every time you load your phone
there's that message every time you look
at your computer there's that message
fix your walls your desk and your
screens to have an empowering message
that you set up once and inspires you
for life step number two is create an
empowering playlist make a playlist of
your favorite songs that get you up they
get you move in the get you bounce and
they get you feeling excited motivated
energized what ends up happening for
a lot of people is when they're feeling
sad when they're feeling low when
they're feeling down and and hating
their life what do they do you put on
really sad music that's the worst thing
that you want to do you want to flip it
music is the fastest way to change your
state to go from a place of feeling
lethargic lazy low energy to feeling up
energetic motivated pumped up the
fastest way to do it is through music
and so create a playlist for you I have
mine I call it my belief playlist it's a
public place so you can find it on my
channel if you want to go and look at it
those are the songs that I listen to
when I need to get get my boost going
those are the songs I listen to first
thing in the morning those are the songs
that I have on at my office while I'm
working not while I listen to YouTube
videos cuz got to pay attention to the
words but otherwise if I'm doing normal
kind of boring menial tasks I've got
that music on it's pumping me up and
fire me up and so there's no one song
that's gonna work for everybody you
already know the songs that make you
feel alive bold moving your body so make
a playlist set it up once and then you
can put that playlist on repeat and
shuffle the song so that you have a
daily consistent hit of inspiration in
your ears and step number three is
change your wardrobe if you're watching
this video dan has a suit Dan likes
walking around in a suit it makes him
feel powerful and special and makes him
think of money and wealth which is what
he's trying to accomplish I love it for
me this is my suit this is my wardrobe I
feel like Batman putting this on I had
these custom design hoodies where these
ones have the special things for the
thumb and the other ones have the orange
inside of the hood and the orange
underneath the arm that that makes me
feel awesome wearing those things and do
I need them to be successful no but I
love putting them on I'm putting on my
Batman suit when I go to work every day
now maybe to you that means nothing
maybe this this is the nastiest thing
you've ever seen in your life awesome
what is the Wardrobe that makes you come
alive that when you put this on it's
time to go to work it's time to crush
your mission it's time to have the most
productive day of all time and so you're
not sitting around in your pajamas
feeling lazy slow lethargic you're going
to work you're putting your Batman suit
on
you're changing your wardrobe what does
that look like for you so remember when
you change your environment it's the
ultimate motivational brain hack because
motivation for most people you have to
wake up and get inspired by watching a
video or reading the
taking some kind of action but when you
change the environment around you it's a
one-time thing that sets you up for life
because you're always walking into this
office and you can always play that
music you can always put on that
wardrobe
so my question of the day for you is
what simple change will you make to your
environment right now let me know put in
the comments below
I'm getting more and more intrigued by
mindset because I used to think of it as
fluffy like self-help and now I think it
more as strategy what's your strategy in
life somebody asked me on Instagram
after I posted a scary if the mindset
has been skewed how can you bring it
back and I answered with by surrounding
yourself with people who have the
mindset you aspire to my friends please
understand that mindset is controllable
in the same way that all our opinions
are controllable the key is to add more
people with optimism and cut people with
negativity it's very very simple now
it's very hard to cut people with
pessimism cynicism and negativity when
they are the people that are the closest
to you parents siblings spouse but the
bottom line is if you're asking the
question I'm gonna give you the answer
the answer is add more people with
positivity and optimism and cut people
with pessimism and cynicism who you
surround yourself matters what content
you consume matters I basically
suffocate myself for a long period of my
time and created an environment that was
based on offense and optimism and now I
know no different please do the same for
you make that move mold and I mean mold
your mindset by what you consume and
with whom you consume it I would argue
that well more than 50% of the people in
this audience are here today because
they worry about the way they would be
judged by one end or two family members
in their inner seven eight people circle
if you're not feeling it find new
friends I'm being dead serious about
this this one is real big for me
who you hang out with is a huge Dion
again these are all trying true things
right we've heard the you're the
whatever of the five friends you spent
like that's real add one new winner
friend like you know what I mean had one
new winner friend and cut one loser
friend like yeah I know he's been your
boy since fourth grade but he sits at
home and smokes weed and plays 2k all
day like you can only love them so much
did you go into politics you should go
to DC if you go into finance New York
movies probably still LA and and tech is
Silicon Valley it has an aspect that's
that's very open very fluid and and it
helps tremendously on these cutting-edge
ideas you want to be in the place where
you can talk to as many people as
possible about your ideas on because
that's the way you will know that
they're cutting edge and you will
improve them even more hi this is Dan
Locke if you're a fan of Evans work if
you want to know exactly how the model
my success I want to invite you to join
me for a special online training all you
have to do is click on a link below you
can join me for absolutely no charge so
click a link below and I will see you in
class
if you want more Dane Locke check out
the top 10 rules video I made on him I
think you'll enjoy it the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there that experience
change how I operate and that that's
hard about this hunger to learn yeah as
much as I could